[Music]
on this Wednesday night new accusations
of Alberta's Premier possibly meddling
in legal cases the damning video of
Danielle Smith leaked can you complete
this with me her defense tonight
sounding the alarm we need to know that
somebody loves them the agony over the
number of people dying in Alberta's
child welfare system
the cost of living in Canada what the
federal budget could mean for inflation
and a huge Outburst of the extra
Galactic kind the significance of this
historic blast in space
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in Alberta where
Premier Danielle Smith is working damage
control with a spring election on the
horizon the Alberta NDP released a phone
conversation between Smith and a
controversial Calgary Pastor who faces
criminal charges for his involvement in
last year's Coots border blockade the
opposition claims the tape raises
questions about the premier's
interference in criminal prosecutions
something Smith has previously denied
Heather your ex West has our top story
tonight
weeks before a rip drop in Alberta the
opposition dropped a bombshell I'm about
to show you a video that was provided to
us recently a cell phone video of a
conversation between Alberta's Premier
and Archer palowski a man facing
criminal charges for inciting people to
continue an illegal border blockade in
Coots in early 2022 being as you are
aware I am still on house arrest
facing 10 10 and a half years of
imprisonment for my speech in Kutz once
the process is underway I can ask our
prosecutors is there a reasonable
likelihood of conviction and is it in
the public interest and I assure you I
have asked them that almost weekly ever
since I got started here the
conversation is believed to have been
recorded in late January just weeks
before pelowski's case was heard in the
Lethbridge courtroom a decision is
expected in early May it's highly
problematic from a rule of law and a
democratic governance perspective the
idea that the premier would be intruding
on prosecutions that are already
underway Premier Daniel Smith issued a
statement just before the video was
released it reads in part as I have
previously stated I had my staff work
with the ministry of Justice to
determine if anything could be done to
Grant amnesty for those charged with
non-violent non-firearms coveted related
charges at no time have I spoke with
anyone from the Alberta Crown
prosecution service nor to my knowledge
have any one of my office's staff
politically this is not something that
the premier wants to be talking about at
this stage she knows it's a losing issue
but the recording has people talking
about it once again with the province's
fixed election date just two months away
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
only three months into 2023 and already
13 young people have died in Alberta's
child welfare system including an 11
year old boy who took his own life a
loved one says this isn't the first time
the family has buried a child who was in
government care she tells Melissa Ridge
and she's fighting to get her own
daughter out before she becomes the next
Grim statistic and a warning some may
find this report disturbing
to even think about suicide at age 11 is
just
incomprehensible it's something no
family should have to experience earlier
this month DJ Baptiste killed himself
near his Calgary foster home family was
told it's shocking to many of us but for
the Baptiste family this is the third
child they've seen die while in
Alberta's child welfare system Kara
Baptiste fell to her death from an
apartment in 2019 sindel Baptiste killed
by a suspected drug overdose last year
this relative who Global News isn't
naming has been fighting to get her own
child home
she doesn't shy away from the reasons
her daughter was put in care in the
first place but says she's been sober
for three years with a good job and a
stable home these clothes are growing
out of her they've been they've been
sitting here since last summer and
um she just needs to come back now I
need her here to to make it a home it
was different for DJ his mother was
murdered in 2015 when he was just three
his father overdosed in 2021 leaving him
orphaned in the system DJ is one of 13
children who've died already this year
according to Alberta's children's
services including three infants one
whose death is being investigated by
Edmonton homicide detectives and a
five-year-old who was mauled by dogs
children's Minister Mickey Amery says
even one preventable death is too many
it is one of the most difficult things
that I have to deal with in this role
and I think it weighs heavily on my
heart and I you know I grieve those
losses just like any other parent would
but critics like Lynn Marshall's they
believe lack of accountability in the
system is why the number of deaths
remain consistent from year to year in
the last decade more than 600 children
have died
I think he's completely out of touch
with what is really happening within
Children's Services
completely out of touch I think he
doesn't know he is listening to the
people within the system he is not
listening to the people that have dealt
with this system or are Advocates we can
decorate her room as she wants in the
meantime this mother says Children's
Services need to return her daughter
until then she fears the worst because
it's already happened to so many the CFS
system is such a beast because it's just
all about the money they're not making
any progress with mental health
addiction education there's no progress
they're moving us backwards
calling for reform and compassion before
she loses anyone else she loves Melissa
ridgeen Global News
reaction to Tuesday's federal budget
continued today with opposition leaders
taking aim at some of the liberal
government's big spending plans While
others took credit for some of the
benefits being offered for everyday
Canadians and as Mackenzie gray reports
neither the criticism or praise has
stopped the Trudeau government from
pitching their plan to the nation
oh is your name Max Christopher Freeland
continuing the tradition of pitching her
plan directly to Canadians even if they
can't vote give me a high five chica
joined by the prime minister they
outline their signature promise from
yesterday's budget A 234 dollar one-time
Top-Up to the GST tax credit to try and
help low-income Canadians with inflation
we're there to support with
affordability we're there to support the
cost of groceries we're there to help
Canadians through the difficult times we
are but in a targeted way that remains
fiscally responsible another measure a
dental care insurance program for
families making less than ninety
thousand dollars
a plan straight from the NDP liberal
Supply and confidence pact because of
new Democrats Dental Care will be
expanded to children under 18 seniors
and people living with disabilities
drug me saying support for the budget
leaves room for the conservatives to
attack the Liberals without worrying
about a potential election all they've
done is raise taxes on businesses that
are trying to create jobs they brought
in a carbon tax that drives away
business despite a looming recession the
Liberals proposed 43 billion dollars in
net new spending which had them
Backtrack on a path to a balanced budget
last November the feds predicted a four
billion dollar Surplus in 2027-2028 but
now they're projecting a 14 billion
dollar deficit for that same year I
think it's fairly telling that even you
know five years old there's there's
really no plan to uh to balance the
books and I I think that's a fairly
important statement the budget will
still have to wind its way through
Parliament before Canadians can start
receiving the benefits and nithu for
some perspective the last budget took
over two months to get Royal ascent
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie so what does this mean for
Canadians as we all deal with the High
Cost of Living and what impact might
this have on the bank of Canada's fight
against inflation our senior business
correspondent Anne gaviola has that part
of the story
the Liberals had to walk a political and
fiscal tightrope with this year's budget
spend enough to get people excited and
clinch continuing NDP support without
overly complicating the bank of Canada's
battle against inflation
the government did manage to uh to kind
of thread the needle and uh walk that
fine line many analysts say this budget
WIll Stoke inflation due to Big Ticket
spending on health and dental care the
green economy and a so-called grocery
rebate this was a big spending big
deficit budget this budget also offers a
slew of consumer-focused measures that
don't come with a big price tag a
Crackdown on so-called junk fees extra
hidden costs on things like concert
tickets an airline baggage plans to
implement standard charging ports for
electronic devices as well as a right to
repair framework to cut down on E-Waste
and hassle bottom line experts say this
won't thwart the central bank's quest to
bring inflation down we don't think that
the budget will add significantly to
inflationary pressure in Canada I don't
think it's so significant that the Bank
of Canada is going to to resume raising
interest rates because of this and yet
consumer Advocates say the measures
don't meaningfully improve affordability
is what comes to mind when I look at how
it will will affect my clientele I'm not
it's nothing to write home about with
deficits projected for the next five
years while the cost of borrowing is
elevated Economist Craig Alexander like
many of his peers worries about what
that will cost us in the future that's
going to be you know 50 billion dollars
of interest that isn't going into
education it isn't going into Health
Care it isn't going into other key
priorities that the country has and it's
because we've been living beyond our
means one thing the budget delivered
predictability a fiscal plan with few
surprises welcomed by many during a time
of economic uncertainty and gaviola
Global News Toronto
Israel's prime minister is fighting U.S
criticism over his contentious judicial
overhaul plan Benjamin Netanyahu says
Israel is a sovereign country and makes
its own decisions it is a rare public
dispute between two long-time allies one
blown into the open after protests
pushed Netanyahu to delay his proposal
Israeli government officials met for a
second round of talks today Netanyahu
says broad consensus is possible crystal
commencing is in Tel Aviv and reports on
a dramatic shift in tone
Israelis Express their anger and
disbelief that a balanced solution to
judicial reforms can be found I said to
my my wife I have no choice I need to go
to the streets because otherwise I I
feel
physically I feel bad I cannot believe
prime minister Benjamin netanyahu's hand
was forced to press pause on those
reforms now a new tone about that last
minute pivot
that's why I've promoted a pause that
now enables both the opposition and the
coalition to sit down and try to achieve
a broad National consensus
International leaders urged Israel to be
cautious about its planned reforms which
included the ability to appoint Supreme
Court judges and overrule decisions not
aligned with the government U.S
President Joe Biden on Tuesday cut to
the chase
cannot continued on this road lawyer
Maurice Hirsch dismisses the idea that
the changes are undemocratic or that
allowing the government to appoint
Supreme Court judges for example would
benefit the government or Netanyahu it's
going to take 28 years to change the
nature of of Israel Supreme Court and
that's on the assumption that only that
same government stays in power for for
that same amount of time the men in
power faces a corruption trial involving
three separate cases on bribery fraud
and breach of trust out in front of the
knesset a lone protester holding a sign
reading shame
I feel ashamed of my country of what
happened to it she really borrowed
distrust the government particularly
because it's propped up by itamar
bengavir's far right religious party and
on Monday he was given a National Guard
to oversee many call it a private
militia if we don't step up and do
something now we're going to end up in a
situation where we won't be able to do
anything at all more protests are
planned for Thursday and Saturday here
in Tel Aviv but tomorrow there will be
both anti and pro reformers taking to
the streets niku crystal gomancing in
Tel Aviv Israel thanks Crystal
all eyes on Vatican City the pope is in
hospital details on his condition coming
up plus stay away the Dutch ad campaign
aimed at certain tourists
Pope Francis has been hospitalized with
a respiratory infection the Vatican says
he is having difficulty breathing and
will be treated in Rome for several days
the 86 year old pontiff does not have
covid-19 Francis appeared in relatively
good form earlier today during his
regularly scheduled General audience
he's still scheduled to celebrate Palm
Sunday service the start of a busy Holy
Week
King Charles has touched down in Germany
for his first state visit abroad since
becoming British monarch
accompanied by Camilla the queen consort
the king received a ceremonial welcome
at the airport and at Berlin's historic
Brandenburg gate today the three-day
visit is being seen as part of the
Royals effort to reset relations with
Europe post brexit King Charles is set
to address the German Parliament
tomorrow a planned trip to France
earlier in the week was canceled due to
ongoing pension protests
a new Dutch ad campaign is asking young
and Rowdy British men planning a wild
and messy night in Amsterdam to stay
away the campaign is specifically
targeted at 18 to 35 year olds and shows
the risks of excessive drug and alcohol
use the online ads will pop up when
people in Britain Search terms like stag
party or pub crawl Amsterdam
[Music]
still ahead Nova Scotia anxiously awaits
a final report on one of the deadliest
shootings in Canadian history
[Music]
next month Mark's three years since a
shooting rampage in Nova Scotia killed
22 people including a pregnant mother
the gunman was shot and killed by police
13 hours after the horror began it's one
of the worst mass shootings in Canadian
history the mass casualty commission
spent months studying what happened and
is set to hand down its final report
tomorrow many hope it will lead to
changes but as Mike Armstrong explains
it will also be another painful day
snag that Dallas
in a place where there was so much pain
there is progress
porta-pic is building a new community
center frown on that one's facing out
something the men putting it up say is
needed oh it's amazing it's amazing to
give the community a chance to have a
place to come heal and think about the
things that are to come the good things
not the bad things right
foreign
things started on a road just a few
hundred meters away although if you
didn't know what to look for you
wouldn't know it was there the gunman's
Cottage was on this property it's
basically been erased it was from here
that he set out on a rampage that killed
22 people and spread a trauma across a
region it was also a crime that left
questions could it have been prevented
could police have reacted better even
what happened exactly we commit to
providing timely and accurate updates
that promise came six weeks after the
mass shootings then the RCMP here didn't
hold a news conference for 10 months
was in a vacuum of information that
families protested calling for a public
inquiry we need closure we need answers
we need the truth
The Province eventually bowed to the
pressure the mass casualty commission
held 76 days of public hearings heard
from 230 Witnesses and released
thousands of exhibits and documents
it hands down its final report Thursday
at this convention center in the town of
Truro the same building the gunman drove
past in his replica police cruiser
during the rampage this was one of the
videos released by the commission those
who fought for this inquiry kudos to
them because at least this will be in
depth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth now there has been criticism
of the inquiry some of the victims
families say the scope became too broad
but the brother of Sean MacLeod says he
hopes what was a painful process leads
to changes we've been hurt and healing
you get a bad cut well you got to stitch
it well Stitch is not going to feel any
better but it's going to help fix it
in advance of the report's release here
tomorrow the commission has given early
copies to victims families and lawyers
for some of the parties involved it's
more than two thousand Pages seven
volumes and makes several dozen
recommendations for people looking at it
this will likely be a late night
preparing for a busy day nithu Mike
Armstrong in Truro Nova Scotia thanks
Mike
brightest blast next the significance of
a historic
story burst in outer space
[Music]
you might have heard of the term goat it
stands for greatest of all time but what
about boat that's what scientists are
calling a cosmic explosion that was so
intense it's earned the nickname
brightest of all time it happened in
October but today we're learning more
about this gamma ray burst that's made
history Eric Sorensen reports
last October 9th this was the largest
natural phenomenon that satellites
looking at Earth probably saw hurricane
Julia making landfall in Central America
but on that very day the world was
suddenly bombarded from outer space we
just didn't notice yet other satellites
like integral from the European space
agency and observatories around the
world instantly registered a burst of
gamma rays high energy radiation that
passes through us every day but usually
in small amounts this was unlike
anything humans have experienced before
even if we didn't feel it but it comes
from a extremely massive star we have
previously seen about ten thousand
gamery bursts since they were first
discovered in the late 1960s this one is
by far the brightest it is likely going
to be the brightest in all of human
civilization up to the state when a star
dies and collapses it pulls everything
into a black hole and from that black
hole a burst of particles is shot out at
the speed of light and from the gas and
surrounding material what streams in
into space are gamma rays plus X-rays
and the visible light that we see even
radio waves but this burst remarkably
came right at the Earth right at us
after traveling 1.9 billion light years
even that dose of gamma rays did not
pose a risk to human health they passed
by and threw us in mere seconds but now
scientists are tracing them back to
where they came from this once in ten
thousand year event was so bright the
so-called Afterglow will be visible for
decades to learn how that star was
formed how it died and what it can tell
us about ourselves and our planet all of
the heavy elements that make up our
Earth and our bodies were formed in
stars and in the deaths of stars and so
if you want to know how we came to be
and where we come from we have to
understand how these elements are fused
there are mysteries about this gamma-ray
burst a supernova would normally have
been seen a few weeks later but the
angle of our own Milky Way galaxy may
have obscured it still scientists now
have lots of data and lots of time
because they likely won't see a
gamma-ray exhibition like this for
another 10 000 years Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday night I'm Nito Garcia
tonight's your Canada is the seat PR
bridge in Saskatoon we love seeing your
Canada please email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks so
much for watching and hope to see you
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]